yeah yo let me ask you this as somebody
who has like you said earlier you know
obviously you struggle with addiction
when you see guys who are former players
um that are are in similar situations
um
I just saw uh
I'm trying to think what's the name of
the guy the lante West is I mean you
know I know Mark Cuban tried to help him
out yeah
um he's still acting up yeah I don't
know what's going on with Ben Gordon but
he seems to not be doing the greatest
yeah but a lot of that [ __ ] is mental
health
I didn't say do you like I never really
I didn't even really understood how
Mental Health
and using drugs is kind of like oh
they're all tied in to the same thing
really
I never really understood that until I
you know
until I'm at the age
that I am right now but I think what
[ __ ] is being truthful with yourself
about you know your situation mentally
yeah
you know what I mean and it takes like
how they say it takes a village to raise
a a child it takes you know
knowing who your friends are
because a lot of us have enablers around
us you know I'm special a lot of these
young black men I'm making a million
dollars like that right yeah everybody
just wants a piece so they're gonna
nobody won't tell them no of course not
even if it's costing you your life
because even if you get high and you get
away with it that day or that night it's
really close to your life
you don't know it right what is the
craziest you're really getting low yeah
man look I think that that's
everyone if if you're supplying
livelihood for people they're gonna look
the other way if you're into some
[ __ ] because if you know how it is
if you're an addict the LA the last
thing you want to be told is the truth
yeah
you know what I'm saying that's the fact
what's the how crazy like drug use wise
what was like the craziest [ __ ] you've
tried
[ __ ] just I mean cocaine in every which
form yeah you feel me
so you've smoked in this crack
basically yeah you you know what's the
difference because I'll be watching
[ __ ] snowfall the high is the
difference is it like that fire
what like smoking crack rock yeah cause
like man people will literally give up
everything to get more of it
it's got to be insane and and I don't
mean that in like a good way but the
high's got to be crazy
it's intense yeah
and for me I'm gonna be honest with you
like
every drug that I did was always tied
into sex too
um
so you would every Rich one yeah
Every Which one so when you were having
sex you obviously get the drugs involved
yeah always makes the sex better always
addicting to sex addictive drugs what
the [ __ ] the same way yeah say Amen
Sexes I mean look man [ __ ] you know feel
me yeah and nowadays
sex is more easy to get than drugs true
you feel me yeah